a lot of people are nervous about where
the economy is headed and many are
wondering what it will mean for the las
vegas housing market which has been
scorching hot for the last couple of
years joining us to discuss that is
radio host and realtor harvey blankfield
along with john ingram thank you both
for being here gentlemen thanks for
having us kendall let me introduce john
john's with prosperity homework he's the
branch manager and he's a lender that we
do a lot of business with and he brings
a lot of knowledge so that's and he's on
the show our radio show regularly and he
brings that knowledge if they want to
hear more from john after today tune
into the radio show tell people when
they can capture saturday mornings at 11
a.m on kdwn every saturday las vegas
real estate now when we talk about all
things real estate that's where on the
dial
101.5 fm 7 20 a.m well let's talk about
these the home prices have been going up
and up but it seems like they're
leveling off a bit at this point yeah
with this the appreciation rate is
slowing down quite a bit and uh
the inventory has been increasing we've
seen it go up uh it was two thousand a
little over 2000 homes at the beginning
of the year it's about 4 000 homes
around the beginning of this month
there's over 5000 single-family homes
available right now so it's been
creeping up it's not at a balanced
market yet but it's getting there it's
getting it's still so it's still seller
side it's not a buyer's market yet but
it's getting a little easier on buyers
do interest rates have anything to do
with that well let's ask john about that
i mean i think so john just recently the
federal government uh raised interest
rates by i believe it was three quarters
of a point correct how does that affect
housing well it's really interesting
because a lot of people would make the
assumption that that increase would
directly move interest rates up on
mortgages yeah and in fact the opposite
happened we saw interest rates decline
after they increased the fed funds rate
by that three-quarters percent so things
actually got a little better this week
not always the case though right
sometimes there is a relationship
absolutely typically there would be the
fed moving that rate up would pressure
mortgage rates up but in this particular
moment in time
mortgages are more heavily reacting to
what's going on with inflation
and when the fed signals that
that they're getting serious about
reacting against inflation mortgages
took that as a real positive sign that
that they can get this heading in the
right direction and they improved
because of that it is interesting to
think about with inflation going the way
it is is inflation going to eat away at
some of the uh equity that people have
built up as a result of the housing
prices going up well you know it's a
great question that for economists i
would have to i'd defer to them but i
would say this is that right now the way
we're seeing things and everything i
hear is houses are going to continue to
appreciate and even if we get into a
recession kendall i'm going to say that
housing should still do very very well
unlike the last recession which was
caused by housing every other recession
we've had in the last five or six
housing is not only held on it's
actually held its own it's actually done
a little bit better my understanding is
that the bubble that existed in 2000
late 2008 seven whatever it was right
was largely in part that people were
over leveraged in this case a lot of
homes have a lot of cash in them now
absolutely you know it's a completely
different uh dynamic right now where you
got back then people could borrow money
just by signing a piece of paper yeah
now now john's comp that no lender will
let anybody borrow a home unless they
can actually afford it yeah they really
vet the buyers very carefully now which
protects everybody in the lab it
protects our market it really does it's
they've done a wonderful job so
anybody's bought a home in the last 20
years knows the mortgage companies are
looking deep deep deep into your
financial history and you've got to also
keep in mind there that for the last 15
years or so 80 plus percent of all
transactions were owner-occupied unlike
what we had previously where everybody
in the world was an investor in the las
vegas market yeah yeah all right good to
hear the optimistic outlook appreciate
you both gentlemen thank you very much
for being here and we want to thank las
vegas real estate for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can visit
lvrealestateradio.com or call that phone
number 702-203-1165
we'll be back